[Música]
las heladeras están vacías
los baños mugrientos hay ropa tirada por
todos lados platos sucios apilados sin
lavar
volvemos caca de mascotas
escuchamos bebés llorando a los gritos
salimos a la calle y hay chicos
deambulando solos
nadie los fue a buscar a la escuela
no es un ataque zombi
este apocalipsis podría generarse si un
día las mujeres nos levantamos si
decidimos no hacer lo que hacemos todos
los días desde ver que los hijos hijas
hijas
se bañen hagan la tarea acompañar a las
personas mayores a las citas médicas
preparan la comida cuidar a los que se
enferman
cada una de estas tareas parece muy
chiquitita
pero sin ellas la sociedad
no funciona
es un espacio de producción
se llama
la economía del cuidado
y aunque son tareas que dejan un valor
muy concreto hoy no reciben ningún pago
en todas las casas se hace este trabajo
todos los días pero de alguna forma no
lo vemos es invisible
probablemente porque para nosotros es
natural corresponde que cada familia
resuelva el cuidado como pueda y en
general se soluciona con el tiempo de
las mujeres
es un asunto íntimo los hijos son
propiedad de las familias con mis hijos
no te metas dicen o si tuviste hijos
acepte cargo
es un asunto tan invisible que ni
siquiera lo vemos cuando lo tenemos
enfrente
se habla mucho de los mini los jóvenes
que no estudian ni trabajan
hace ya seis años desde cippec haciendo
un trabajo en provincia de buenos aires
descubrimos que en realidad tres de cada
cuatro jóvenes que no están trabajando
estudiando ni buscando trabajo
son chicas
que tienen a cargo el cuidado de sus
hermanos sus abuelos o sus hijos
en definitiva no existen los niños
existen mujeres cuidadoras
las mujeres más pobres tienen la carga
más grande dedican ocho horas y media
por día un poco más que una jornada
laboral normal al cuidado
tienen que dedicar tanto tiempo porque
en los contextos donde viven es
muchísimo más difícil gestionar el
cuidado
no hay cloacas por ejemplo entonces los
chicos se enferman nada si hay que
llevarlos más al hospital
si estas mujeres decidieran salir a
trabajar de forma remunerada los empleos
que conseguirían pagan tan mal que ni
siquiera les alcanzaría para reemplazar
lo que ellas mismas hacen adentro de sus
casas
pierden plata saliendo a trabajar
y además se exponen a situaciones
riesgosas
anna por ejemplo es de pampa de los
guanacos en santiago del estero
ella trabajaba en la capital como
empleada doméstica y había veces que no
podía volver a su casa por semanas
enteras ni ver a sus hijos
ahora estaba en la informalidad lo cual
es muy común todavía hoy tres de cada
cuatro personas que trabajan en el
sector del empleo doméstico no están
registradas
yo la conocí por un proyecto y ella me
contó que trabajó muchísimos años en la
misma casa esa era como de la familia
comía con todos las llevaban de
vacaciones
pero así como en esa casa a los hijos
les pegaban
a ella también la llegaron a maltratar
anna me dijo que ella no quiere nunca
más dejar a sus hijos para ir a trabajar
porque querría
no se trata solamente de la plata que
podría ganar sino de todo lo que tiene
para perder
cuando la única opción es quedarse
cuidando
es mucho más probable que esas familias
con suerte tengan un único ingreso que
encima suele ser bastante más bajo
y es así como esas familias y en
particular esas mujeres están en una
trampa en la que quedan atrapados
también sus hijos y sus nietos
soy esta situación parecida a una estafa
piramidal
nos ponemos pero acá en vez de poner
plata lo que se pone es tiempo y
esperamos que no se den los beneficios
pero todos nos vemos perjudicados de
alguna forma
las familias con más ingresos nos vemos
perjudicadas porque terminamos siendo
cómplices de algo de lo que nadie quiere
ser parte
se saca ventaja de la situación de
vulnerabilidad en la que vive una parte
importante de la sociedad
es una trampa sistémica la falta de
oportunidades lleva eso
las mujeres con menos ingresos dan su
tiempo a las familias de clases medias y
altas y es por eso que tanto varones
como mujeres de esas familias podemos
salir a trabajar
pero a las mujeres más pobres nadie les
da tiempo
ellas también tienen que cuidar no
tienen los recursos nadie cuida de ellas
acá nadie gana no es que hay un
estafador detrás todos perdemos porque
se amplifican la pobreza y la
desigualdad
esta situación me parece un ciclo
vicioso así sin salida en realidad
no tiene por qué ser así
podemos romper esta trampa que deja a
familias por generaciones en la pobreza
y hay muchas cosas con las que empezar
primero reconocer el valor que tiene
este trabajo que hacemos las mujeres
el cuidado está atravesado por el amor
está lleno de gratificaciones
pero no por eso deja de ser un trabajo
tenemos que lograr que las mujeres que
trabajan profesionalmente en el cuidado
lo hagan en buenas condiciones
que es un trabajo digno y bien
remunerado formal que le sirva a hacerlo
para eso es fundamental que esté mejor
representado
nos imaginamos a una senadora que se ha
empleado doméstica
a las mujeres que cuidan a tiempo
completo en sus propias casas también
hay que reconocerles ese trabajo
por ejemplo incluyendo en los cálculos
de las jubilaciones los años dedicados a
la crianza y el cuidado formalmente como
se hace en españa
qué pasaría si los varones toman una
parte de este trabajo de cuidados una
parte mayor para que deje de ser una
cosa predominantemente de mujeres
personalmente me asusta un poco como la
gente asume que yo voy a saber qué hacer
en dos meses cuando nazca mi primera
hija maya y nadie pretende lo mismo de
mi marido
quiero proponerles un ejercicio ahora
todos los que vinieron hoy quiero
pedirles a los varones que vivan con una
mujer y puede ser cualquier mujeres
puede ser su pareja su madre su hija un
amigo una hermana todos los varones que
ven con una mujer por favor que se paren
manu arias bueno ahora quiero pedirles a
todos los que se pararon que sobre un
montón si ustedes no lavaron ropa en la
última semana y esto incluye usar el
lavarropas lavar a mano llevar al ave
rap si ustedes no cumplieron esta
función siéntense
quedaron algunos pocos pero quedaron
ahora quisiera pedirles a los que se
sentaron si ustedes estarían dispuestos
a distribuir estas tareas de una forma
más justa adentro de sus casas por favor
que se vuelvan a parar
bueno gracias se pueden sentar todos un
aplauso por favor a los que participaron
fotos como estas todavía son raras
hay avances claramente muchos son mas
discursivos que reales
esta foto formó parte de una muestra que
montamos en la estación de tren desde
buenos aires en retiro para contribuir
al cambio cultural que tanto se necesita
porque ni los varones que quieren hacer
más trabajos de cuidado sí que saben lo
que se pierden ni la sociedad ni el
mercado de trabajo se los termina de
permitir
hasta las leyes terminan diciendo el
cuidado es responsabilidad de mujeres
en argentina por ejemplo la licencia por
maternidad es de 90 días y la licencia
por paternidad de dos días ya hay muchos
países que salieron de esta situación no
es algo que pasa solamente en la serie
de suecas en netflix es estoy hablando
de uruguay y ecuador
en argentina con dos días de licencia
por paternidad les estamos diciendo a
los varones que ellos tienen que cuidar
a su trabajo les estamos diciendo a las
mujeres que ellas tienen que cuidar a
sus hijos y les estamos diciendo a las
empresas que tienen que contratar
varones
como sociedad nos pusimos de acuerdo en
que la educación la salud las
jubilaciones son cosas que queremos
hacer entre todos
por eso están garantizadas por el estado
el cuidado es un pilar igual de
importante pero tenemos tan naturalizado
que es un tema familiar que las
políticas públicas de cuidado parecen un
lujo que no podemos darnos
una mayor inversión en una
infraestructura y en un sistema de
cuidados podría ayudarnos a nivelar la
cancha podríamos asegurar que todos los
chicos y chicas tengan buenas
oportunidades desde esos primeros
momentos de vida que son tan esenciales
también podríamos mejorar las
condiciones de las familias en pobreza
si todos los adultos de esas familias
pudiesen contar con ingresos propios
pero
de donde saldrían esos trabajos
con unos colegas demostramos que podrían
generarse a partir de la misma inversión
en cuidados por ejemplo garantizar que
dos tercios de los chicos que hoy tienen
menos de cuatro años asista algún
espacio de crianza enseñanza o cuidado
generaría casi 1.300.000 puestos de
trabajo
un poco más de un tercio de lo que se
necesita para las oportunidades de los
que hoy no tienen
se necesitarían personas que trabajan en
la construcción de estos espacios que
eduquen que cuiden que cocinen que
transporten los alimentos que se
necesitan para cocinar que los cultiven
el efecto es multiplicador
estimamos que esto haría crecer a la
economía en 53 puntos del pbi en un
período de cuatro años
quien se hubiese imaginado que los
jardines de infantes tenían un impacto
tan grande en nuestro desarrollo
esta tensión entre el trabajo y el
cuidado me está atravesando muy
vívidamente en los últimos meses
pregunto a toda persona que se me acerca
y vos cómo te organizas tratando de
descifrar cómo se hace esto de tener
hijos y seguir trabajando
cuando yo nací mi mamá también trabajaba
todo el día acá sin asco en su estudio y
me cuido mi abuela clara me encantaba
estar con ella
yo sé que mi mamá se muere de ganas ella
está desesperada por el amor que tiene
ella por esta futura nieta pero sé que
no la va a poder cuidar primero porque
sigue trabajando y segundo porque vive
en bariloche y yo vivo acá en buenos
aires
mi marido trabaja en un lugar con muy
poca flexibilidad y
tampoco es una opción
por suerte es mi suegra se ofreció a
cuidar la malla y eso me deja tranquila
aunque mi casa no va a caer en ese
apocalipsis doméstico pero de nuevo
es a costa del tiempo de otra mujer
siempre es a costa del tiempo de otra
mujer una mujer de otra generación o una
mujer de otra clase social
terminamos perpetuando la trampa
yo quiero que rompamos la trampa da
invisible quiero que las mujeres seamos
dueñas de nuestro tiempo
quiero que todos los chicos y chicas
tengan buenas oportunidades desde esos
primeros momentos de vida
y quiero que la pobreza deje de ser una
condena por generaciones
[Aplausos]
y sé que podemos hacerlo porque está
demostrado hace más de 50 años por
pioneras de la economía feminista que
las políticas públicas de cuidado
reducen la pobreza y la desigualdad
por eso quiero que haya más espacios de
cuidado más jardines de infantes que las
que cuidan lo hagan en buenas
condiciones y que nos pongamos de
acuerdo aunque esto es algo que también
tenemos que empujar entre todos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]